die afrikanische schweinepest rückt
immer näher an deutschland heran bereits
tausende infizierte tiere sind aus
osteuropa gemeldet worden die neuesten
infektionsherde in polen sind gerade
einmal 300 bis 400 kilometer von
deutschland entfernt ihr habt euch
dieses thema bei whatsapp gewünscht und
bekommt jetzt alle facts zur
afrikanischen schweinepest wie groß ist
die gefahr dass sie solche jetzt auch
nach deutschland eingeschleppt wird und
wie wollen die behörden die pest unter
kontrolle bekommen jetzt in kriegs und
science fiction herzlich willkommen
70 prozent aller wildschweine in
deutschland müssen getötet werden und
schon jetzt sind allein in bayern 13.000
wildschweine erlegt worden
zitat die infektion ist eine reale und
ernsten bedrohung für deutschland
so die einschätzung von thomas
mettenleiter präsident des
friedrich-loeffler-instituts für
tiergesundheit konkret spricht er von
dem afrikanischen schweinepest virus das
ausschließlich haus und wildschweine
befällt ein ausbruch in deutschland
hätte katastrophale folgen für die
landwirtschaft deutschland zählt zu den
größten schweinefleisch produzenten
weltweit
die übertragung kann auf verschiedenen
wegen passieren beispielsweise durch den
kontakt von kranken und gesunden tieren
aber auch indirekt durch die fütterung
mit abfällen die infizierte
schweinefleisch enthalten als erste
symptome sind dann hohes fieber
durchfall erbrechen und koordinierte
bewegung zu beobachten
oft sterben die tiere innerhalb von 48
stunden das große problem es gibt keinen
impfstoff bislang schaffen es die
behörden tatsächlich nicht die seuche
einzudämmen
in der tschechischen stadt flint
beispielsweise wurden drei bekämpfung
stone eingerichtete dieses vorgehen galt
lange als vorbild auch für die deutschen
behörden
doch trotzdem wurden im januar zehn
infizierte wildschweine außerhalb des
gebietes gefunden und ja klar
elektrozäune können zwar großflächig
eingesetzt werden doch können nicht
ganze straßen und dörfer komplett
abgeriegelt werden
das gebiet liegt übrigens nur 300
kilometer von der grenze zu sachsen und
bayern entfernt und jetzt ist ein neuer
infektionsherd entdeckt worden im
nördlichen polen
dort wo im januar alleine 312 fälle
registriert wurden also der am stärksten
betroffene eu staat und auch hier ist
die deutsche grenze nicht weit
mecklenburg vorpommern liegt eben etwa
nur 400 kilometer entfernt und es werden
immer mehr fälle gemeldet 4140 fälle
waren es im jahr 2017 östlich von
deutschland also unter anderem in polen
den baltischen staaten und tschechien im
ganzen jahr 2014 waren es nur 3 104
fälle allein im januar 2018 sind es aber
allein schon 359 fälle
fest steht also die ausbreitung des
virus hat nicht an dynamik verloren im
gegenteil expertinnen gehen davon aus
dass sich der virus erreger in ländern
wie ost polen litauen und estland
mittlerweile schon etabliert hat und er
so innerhalb einer schweine population
immer weiter an neue tiere weitergeben
das gegenteil wäre wünschenswert gewesen
nämlich dass sich die krankheit tod
läuft doch es ist fast unmöglich die
solche in den wildbeständen unter
kontrolle zu bekommen
denn auch wenn weniger tiere an der
afrikanischen schweinepest erkranken als
an der maul und klauenseuche halten sich
die erreger sehr lange in den
infizierten kadavern noch die experten
sind sich einig das größte risiko dass
die solche auch nach deutschland
eingeschleppt wird liegt beim menschen
und nicht bei der übertragung von tier
zu tier kontaminierte schweineprodukte
gelang innerhalb von kürzester zeit
viele tausend kilometer weit die
ausbruchs geschwindigkeit bei der tier
zu tier übertragung liegt nach angaben
ja bisher bei so maximal 30 kilometern
pro jahr
fest steht jedenfalls der ausbruch der
seuche in deutschland hätte fatale
auswirkungen auf die tiergesundheit und
den handel
zitat die volkswirtschaftlichen und
gesellschaftlichen auswirkungen eines
ausbruchs der afrikanischen schweinepest
sind kaum vorstellbar
bereits das auftreten im
wildschweinbestand würde bedeuten dass
kein schweinefleisch mehr in drittländer
also in länder außerhalb der eu
exportiert werden kann so der
bauernverband in einer offiziellen
mitteilung
das friedrich-loeffler-institut für
tiergesundheit warnt eindringlich davor
schweine bzw wildschweine fleisch wie
schinken oder salami aus den betroffenen
ländern mit nach deutschland zu bringen
und ich habe es ja eben schon kurz
erwähnt bislang ist kein impfstoff
verfügbar und auch in naher zukunft
können wir darauf nicht setzen bauern
werden jetzt aufgerufen ihre schweine
stelle zu sichern
der bauernverband fordert zudem die
vorbeugende tötung von etwa 70 prozent
des wildschwein bestandes auch von der
politik wie etwa der csu wird diese
forderung unterstützt das ist übrigens
die bedingungen der european food safety
agency also der europäischen agentur für
lebensmittelsicherheit um die
schweinepest wirkungsvoll zu bekämpfen
in einigen bundesländern wurden jetzt
tatsächlich auch schon die jagd
bedingungen erleichtert eben 13.000
erlegte wildschweine in bayern zudem
soll noch in diesem monat ein
schweinepest krisen gipfel stattfinden
wenn ihr kein video zu diesem thema und
auch zu allen anderen themen verpassen
wollt dann endet einfach meine
telefonnummer whatsapp dann bekommt ihr
die videos vor allen anderen von mir
geschickt direkt garantiert immer ihr
könnt dort über mich in der redaktion
von krieg so mitmachen und mit themen
vorschlagen oder an abstimmungen
teilnehmen und mitbestimmen was hier bei
pixum passiert der die
draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken
das ist der direkte link zu meiner
nummer und natürlich nicht das aber mit
der genauen blogger vergessen hier geht
es weiter mit auch dafür draufklicken
riesigen todeszone vor der us küste
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran